hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website move university I found
thanks and enjoy the video okay so I
want to begin our discussion here of
lipids with a brief introduction so what
are lipids one thing I'll mention before
we actually go into these notes is that
lipids are one of the four classes of
macromolecules and a lot of the times
lipids people are asked we know lower
lipids they'll just answer all lipids
those are fats that's not really correct
I mean there is some truth to it but
it's not correct fats are can be
classified of course under lipids but
not all lipids are fats lipids are
molecules that are insoluble in water
and soluble in organic solvents so what
does that mean what kind of molecules
are insoluble in water and soluble in
organic solvents basically it's
molecules that are mostly hydrophobic or
mostly nonpolar right because things
that are nonpolar or hydrophobic don't
dissolve in water but they do dissolve
or are soluble in organic solvents now
you'll notice the word mostly here has
an asterisk and the reason why is that
these molecules don't have to be
entirely hydrophobic or entirely
nonpolar that can be amphipathic or
amphiphilic what that is basically
saying those terms are defined are
defined by the idea that a molecule can
contain both polar and nonpolar portions
or hydrophilic and hydrophobic portions
so that's what these from these terms
refer to so you might think to yourself
okay we know what lipids are what are
different functions of lipids and the
short answer is that they can vary
widely there's a bunch of different
functions for instance one of them is
that lipids can store energy there are
some that make up membranes there are
some that can act as hormones
and hormones are signaling molecules
others play a role as key nutrients I
think some of the vitamins are lipids
but this the nutrients bit I'm not
really going to talk too much about but
these these other three here are
definitely things that I'm going to
mention in future videos okay so now the
question is we know that lipids are one
of the four classes of macromolecules
the other three being carbohydrates
proteins and nucleic acids but what sets
them apart from those other three
classes and there is something key here
and that is that there's no monomer
polymer situation going on if you recall
carbohydrates right the monomer units of
carbohydrates are monosaccharides and
the polymers are polysaccharides in the
case of proteins the monomers are amino
acids the polymers are polypeptides when
of course when they fold can can become
proteins are called proteins and then
nucleic acids the monomeric units are
nucleotides so what's going on with
lipids well lipids don't actually have
that sort of situation going on there
aren't any polymer or polymeric units or
monomeric units as you'll see when we
discuss the structures of these
different classes speaking of which here
they are so one class is free fatty
acids so free fatty acids are actually
the simplest lipid and they're actually
used for fuel in fact if you've watched
the videos on fatty acid oxidation or
beta oxidation or fatty acid synthesis
you can understand why this is the case
well specifically beta oxidation I'll
probably have a link somewhere in an
annotation at this point ok the next
class is tri so glycerols or
triglycerides those are used for fuel
storage we'll talk about the difference
between being used for fuel and fuel
storage in fact I'll even mention it now
free fatty acids can be directly
oxidized in beta oxidation to yield
acetyl COAS that I eventually give you
energy whereas triacylglycerols and
triglycerides
they actually are purely the storage
form of energy and we'll talk more about
that later another class or let's just
go through all three of these classes
here three are phospholipids
four we got sphingolipids and then five
here we got glycol lipids so so these
three are I sort of grouped them
together as membrane lipids these can
kind of be classified in a variety of
ways but they are all membrane lipids
phospholipids have phosphate group
sphingolipids have a sphingosine
backbone glycol lipids have sugar
moieties attached to them we'll talk
more about that in future videos and the
last one I've got here is steroids and
steroids are important in in membranes
and they're also important as hormones
or signaling molecules so I hope that
video was a helpful introduction thank
you for watching yo if you found that
video helpful don't forget a like
comment subscribe for more content and
if you know anybody who might find the
videos helpful then please share with
them Thanks happy studying